vean este capacitor vean qué sucede si
lo conecto a este foco
si nada sucedió porque el capacitor no
está cargado pero si lo conectamos
primero a una batería para que se cargue
el capacitor y después lo conectamos al
foco el foco se va a encender
y la razón de que esto ocurra es porque
cuando está cargado un capacitor no solo
almacena carga sino que también almacena
energía cuando conectamos el capacitor a
la batería las cargas se separan de
estas cargas separadas van a querer
reunirse de nuevo en cuanto tengan la
oportunidad ya que los opuestos se
atraen
así que si completamos el circuito con
algunos alambres y un foco la corriente
va a fluir y la energía almacenada en el
capacitor se vuelve luz y calor que
salen del foco
una vez que el capacitor se descarga a
sí mismo y ya no hay más cargas que
transferir el proceso termina y la luz
se apaga
el tipo de energía almacenada en los
capacitores es energía potencial
eléctrica si queremos encontrar la
cantidad de energía almacenada en un
capacitor necesitamos recordar cuál es
la fórmula de la energía potencial
eléctrica si una carga que se mueve a
través de un voltaje ve el cambio en la
energía potencial eléctrica de esa carga
es q polvo observando esta fórmula cual
creen ustedes que será la energía en un
capacitor que ha sido cargado hasta una
carga cv y un voltaje de q por ver si
eso es lo que yo también había pensado
pero resulta que la energía almacenada
en el capacitor es un medio por q por
ver de dónde viene este un medio cómo es
que la energía no es simplemente q por b
bueno la energía almacenada en un
capacitor sería q por b si durante la
descarga todas las cargas cayeran del
total del voltaje b pero durante la
descarga
todas las cargas van a caer a través del
voltaje total ve de hecho solo la primer
carga que es transferida va a caer a
través del total del voltaje de todas
las cargas que sean transferidas después
van a caer a través de cada vez menos
voltaje la razón de esto es que cada vez
que una carga es transferida decrementar
la cantidad total de carga almacenada en
el capacitor y conforme disminuye la
carga del capacitor el voltaje a través
del capacitor también va a disminuir
recuerden que la capacitancia se define
como la carga almacenada en el capacitor
entre el voltaje a través de ese
capacitor así que conforme disminuye la
carga el voltaje también disminuye
conforme más carga es transferida
llegará un punto en el que la carga solo
va a tener una caída a través de tres
cuartos a través del voltaje inicial si
esperamos un poco más nos encontramos
que la caída de la carga va a ser a
través de un medio del voltaje original
y esperamos un poco más nos encontramos
que la carga va a tener una caída de un
cuarto del voltaje original y la última
carga que se transfiere va a caer casi
nada de voltaje porque básicamente no
quedará carga en el capacitor si
sumáramos todas las caídas de energía
potencial eléctrica nos encontraríamos
que la caída total de energía en el
capacitor es q la carga total inicial en
el capacitor multiplicado por la mitad
del voltaje original del capacitor así
que básicamente este un medio está aquí
porque no toda la carga va a tener una
caída a través de todo el voltaje
inicial ve en promedio la caída de la
carga a través de sólo la mitad del
voltaje original así que si tomamos la
carga almacenada en un capacitor en
cualquier momento y la multiplicamos por
el voltaje a través del capacitor en ese
mismo instante y lo dividimos entre 2
tendremos la energía almacenada en el
capacitor en ese instante particular de
tiempo hay otra forma de esta ecuación
que nos puede ser útil
la capacitancia se define como la carga
entre el voltaje podemos reescribir esto
como la carga igual a la capacitancia
por el voltaje si sustituimos
capacitancia por voltaje en lugar de la
carga veremos que la energía del
capacitor también puede escribirse como
un medio por la capacitancia por el
voltaje a través del capacitor al
cuadrado pero ahora tenemos un problema
en una de estas fórmulas la b es al
cuadrado y en una de estas fórmulas la b
no está al cuadrado y yo tenía problemas
para recordar cuál era cuál pero ahora
me acuerdo de esta manera si usamos la
fórmula que tiene al ac entonces
tendremos la b al cuadrado y si usamos
la fórmula que no tiene enlace pues no
tendremos la abe al cuadrado estas son
las dos fórmulas de la energía
almacenada en un capacitor pero debemos
tener cuidado ya que el voltaje ve en
estas fórmulas se refiere al voltaje a
través de un capacitor y no es
necesariamente el voltaje de la batería
que no
indiquen en el problema si tenemos este
caso sencillo en donde hay un capacitor
conectado a una sola batería entonces en
este caso el voltaje a través de el
capacitor sí será igual al voltaje de la
batería así que si una batería de 9
voltios está cargando un capacitor a una
carga máxima de 4 coloms entonces la
energía almacenada por el capacitor será
de 18 jules ya que el voltaje a través
del capacitor va a ser el mismo que el
voltaje de la batería pero si tenemos el
caso en donde tenemos varias baterías
conectadas a varios capacitores entonces
para encontrar la energía almacenada en
un solo capacitor tendremos que usar el
voltaje a través de ese capacitor en
particular en otras palabras si tenemos
estos circuitos con estos datos de
voltaje en cada capacitor podremos
encontrar la energía almacenada en el
capacitor de en medio usando un medio
por q por ver solo debemos tener cuidado
de usar el voltaje que pasa a través de
ese capacitor y no
el voltaje de las baterías si usamos 5
columnas para la carga nos encontramos
que la energía es de 7.5 jules